"THE FIVE."
>> BEARS ARE SMART.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON, AND
BRET BAIER.
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION SAYS
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TOLD THE TOP
OFFICIAL UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR POTENTIAL GUN
PURCHASERS ARE OFF THE TABLE.
THAT NEWS COMING SHORTLY AFTER
THE PRESIDENT HELD COURT ON A
WIDE ARRAY OF TOPICS, INCLUDING
GUN CONTROL.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS WAS AT THE
IMPROMPTU PRESS CONFERENCE.
>> ALMOST A FULL BLOWN PRESS
CONFERENCE.
WE WERE IN THE OVAL OFFICE FOR
ABOUT HALF AN HOUR.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE
FOR THE PRESIDENT, HE SEEMED TO
BACK OFF ON HIS EARLIER SUPPORT
FOLLOWING THE EL PASO AND DAYTON
SHOOTINGS FOR ENHANCED
BACKGROUND CHECKS, PERHAPS NOT
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS BUT
AT LEAST CLOSINGS AND LOOPHOLES.
THE PRESIDENT LEAVING
BEDMINSTER, NEW JERSEY, OVER THE
WEEKEND, APPEARED TO BACK OFF ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT AND NOW WE
HAVE LEARNED FROM NRA SOURCES
THAT THE PRESIDENT CALLED
WAYNE LaPIERRE THIS AFTERNOON
AND TOLD HIM THAT UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE OFF THE
TABLE.
WITHOUT MENTIONING BACKGROUND
CHECKS, WAYNE LaPIERRE TWEETED
"I SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT TODAY,